- Do ever get anything wrong?
What do you do
when you make a mistake?
- I get everything wrong
it's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong
I'm moving on to the next thing.
Dwelling on what
you fucked up on
is the quickest way for
the next thing not to work.
Right?
- [Shira] Yeah.
(audience applause)
- I think I do everything,
I mean you know this.
This is a fun thing to say.
Some people in
the back know this.
I was a breakout YouTube
star in the first year.
2006. I decided that
the right strategy was
to leave YouTube completely
and go to Viddler because
Viddler offered me equity
in their company and
I've left an enormous amount
of attention, I deviated
from my attention thesis
to do short term economics
and equity in a company
and I lost.
I lost. When DRock finally
came in my life two years ago
and we started to try to build
up my YouTube the first time,
I was sitting on 40,000 followers
in a world where
I could have had millions
if I just stayed the course.
So, I make
mistakes all the time,
I'm re-org'ing
VaynerMedia every day
'cause it's based on a mistake
I made the prior year.
I just don't give a
fuck about my mistakes,
everybody else cares
about your mistakes.
If you're worried about
your own mistakes,
you've already lost.
("Exhipopyo" by Kwesibeats)